fa la politique à suivre catherine zola
taux va me rejoindre et nous allons
parler des projets pour l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines robert
cadalbert président socialiste tenait
hier sa cérémonie de voeux aux
personnalités et justement les voeux
pour 2013 que peut-on vous souhaiter
micro trottoir du travail pour les
jeunes de la tranquillité pour les plus
âgés et que le centre commercial soit le
plus dynamique pour cible ce qui là elle
était jusqu'à présent la sortie du
boulot pour tout le monde surtout pour
les jeunes
voilà beaucoup de bonheur santé et quel
pouvoir d'achat il passe un petit peu
pour toutes les décisions français
glanaient wan saw des photos de monde
tout au long du mois de janvier le point
sur les différentes cérémonies de voeux
des élus locaux trappe magny les hameaux
guyancourt ce soir l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines pour faire
catherine dont south
il y avait du monde mardi soir lors des
voeux du président de l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines
traditionnellement organisée au théâtre
il y avait du monde a rejoint la cité
tout le monde parce que le théâtre était
plein on peut dire que en tout cas les
les maires des sept communes qui
composent la communauté d'agglomération
à l'exception du maire de trappes guy
malandain qui était retenu pour des
raisons familiales il y avait aussi le
ministre de l'économie sociale et
solidaire toujours très présent sur le
secteur ne cesse de l'audi il y avait
des députés des conseillers généraux
la sénatrice socialiste catherine tasca
est le maître mot de cette soirée
c'était l'art et la manière les robert
cadalbert c'est presque surprenant
annoncer des bonnes nouvelles
économiques banon pourquoi surprenante
parce que dans cette période difficile
entre les suppressions de postes
d'écouté de ses salles et oui mais les
voeux c'est le moment où on se dit les
bonnes nouvelles et les bonnes nouvelles
sont économie du côté de l'agglomération
avec l'installation ou l'extension de
plusieurs entreprises comme mercedes
baxter le crédit agricole
europcar colas carré privé ou encore la
rénovation deux start
il ya aussi il est aussi été question de
l'intercommunalité lors de cette
cérémonie le périmètre de saint quentin
en yvelines qui n'est pas modifiée on en
avait parlé sur sa tombe alors la fin du
mois de décembre il fallait décider il
fallait se mettre en intercommunalité ou
agrandir son intercommunalité en tout
cas là c'est sur la peau médiation ce
soir l'état est tout à fait une
obligation légale
là c'est sûr la première nous
il n'y a pas de modification du
périmètre de saint quentin en yvelines
et robert cabé le pré un socialiste a
quand même reconnu que plusieurs
communes souhaitait faire leur entrée
dans la casse qui alors certes donc le
périmètre ne va pas évoluer dans un
avenir proche
mais le président reconnaît qu'il va
falloir réfléchir avec toutes les villes
qui souhaitent travailler avec 50,1
alors ça veut dire en gros que la porte
n'est pas fermée on pense évidemment à
maurepas ou à coignières et bien entendu
pourquoi pas également la ville de
plaisir non feint certainement que tout
cela ne se décidera qu'après les
municipales de mars 2008 14 on y viendra
donc plus clair et c'est le président de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines jean luc baissière qui a dû
être content puisqu'il est question de
l'université lors de ses voeux oui tout
à fait parce que on a rappelé qu'
évidemment cette année en 2012 l'année
dernière par nom a été inauguré
l'université de versailles saint quentin
et c'était aussi l'occasion de rappeler
qu'en 2013 la maison des étudiants
construite par la région va entrer en
phase chantier et que 1000 logements
étudiants supplémentaires seront
construits à elancourt à guyancourt et à
montigny et puis une autre arrivée celle
ci ce sera en 2015 mais on l'annoncé
quand même c'est d'une nouvelle école
l'école devient l'estaca qui va
s'installer montini c'est une école qui
forme aux métiers de l'aéronautique et
du spatial les transports et c'est
important la première phase de la
transformation de la gare de saint
quentin en yvelines est bien entamée et
oui la gare a été reconfiguré un haut
niveau des espaces de passage de
commerce de ses accès et les travaux de
la gare se poursuivront jusqu'en 2014
avec une nouvelle gare routière côté
rn10 sur le nouveau boulevard qui
s'appelle paul delouvrier où aller il
faudra s'habituer à ce nouveau nom et
des aménagements sont également prévues
au niveau du pôle gare de la verrière
alors ça c'est vraiment une bonne
nouvelle aussi le doublement du pont
schuller a été actée on en parle depuis
plusieurs années le prolongement de la
ligne c du rer jusqu'à coignières oui
tout à fait robert calvet a évidemment
évoqué ce prolongement dans le cadre des
projets d'urbanisme de la région ile de
france et il a annoncé aussi que dans le
cadre de la tangentielle ouest qui doit
relier je le rappelle alors saint
germain en laye à saint-cyr-l'ecole en
2018 bien ce cadre des études sont en
cours pour une connexion avec saint
quentin en yvelines
voilà on voit sur ces images ce que cela
pourrait donner
il a aussi évoqué alors le dossier du
métro automatique du grand paris
et du coup l'agglomération a dit qu'elle
souhaiterait une interconnexion entre la
ligne c du rer la tangentielle ouest
dont on vient de parler et puis la ligne
verte du métro l'idée c'est évidemment
d'aller de saint quentin en yvelines
vers le rer rer à saint germain en laye
et puis de l'autre côté vers un massy
orly ça c'est des projets les soit 6 me
autre nouvelle concernant les transports
des études sont menées pour réaliser un
transport automatique léger pour
desservir satory le technocentre de
renault guyancourt et le golfe pour 2018
à partir de versailles chantiers
chantier qui débutera justement en 2013
l'ouverture du vélodrome à mon team avis
assez important et alors à mettre dans
le rayon des possibles on va dire ça
comme ça autour de ce vélodrome
l'accueil des championnats de france en
2014 et peut-être l'accueil des
championnats du monde en 2016 en tout
cas sur sûrement cette année en 2013
le centre national du cyclisme va
s'installer et toujours en sport la
ryder cup 2018 ça c'est la compétition
qui réunit les meilleurs golfeurs au
monde à leur allié au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en 2018 c'est
un peu loin mais toutefois il ya une
association qui vient de se créer de
soutien la ryder cup est sur le plateau
du 7-8 on recevra le président de
l'association c'est joël neault il
viendra mardi 22 janvier alors que les
meilleurs américains contre les
meilleurs européens
on espère qu'il aura des français
pourquoi pas des saint-quentinois et on
a quelques années pour pour s'y préparer
la culture rapidement juste pour dire
que l'agglomération sont en tout cas
bien ouvrir mal à ouvrir nos golf au
plus grand nombre donc voilà on aura
peut-être un saint quentinois en 2018
sur les sur les greens vert après le
sport la culture rapidement voilà tout à
fait et puis un clin d'oeil pour
terminer ses voeux c'est avec la troupe
déclic théâtre qui fête cette année ses
20 ans et la troupe de théâtre
d'improvisation a investi la scène du
théâtre national ils sont venus avec
leur patinoire et les comédiens ont joué
des petits textes autour de thèmes comme
les débuts où l'art et la manière et
puis il faut juste pour l'anecdote dire
qu'à la fin à la fin de ceux de ceux de
cette séance d'improvisation et une
improvisation très remarqué qu'ils
présentent cas d'albert qui abondera
betclic c'était assez réussi et
l'intéressé s'est beaucoup amusé et le
rd spectateurs aussi merci quatrième
prochain point la semaine prochaine sur
ces différentes cérémonies de voeux la
verrière voisins le bretonneux notamment
n'oubliez pas que vous retrouvez ses
différents comptes rendus sur notre site
internet la culture le mercredi c'est
avec johanna soudry et c'est tout de
suite